i have
so many stories of combat and things
like this but
at the end of the day
i know there's
thousands of guys like me
um
that have stories like
this um
and there's almost like a
a stigma
that
you can't talk about
stuff like this and
i want to try
through this
to try to break that down a little bit
because guys are dying
and
not in combat
we're coming back
and
guys i know
personally coming back and killing
themselves
because
i believe
they're not talking
they're not letting people know that
they're in pain
because they think they need to bury
that down
which i understand that's taught
in
them
i don't know how to
you don't talk about these things in the
marines you bury it down and you stay
combat ready
i want to
try
somehow
keep in mind this this isn't easy
i don't talk about this [ __ ] i i can't
i hope that
these stories that i'm telling you guys
like it but
you got to understand
how hard it is for us to talk about this
stuff
this shit's real
guys that we
train every day with that
they're dying
we
we are over there
protecting our country's freedoms
and
we're coming home
and we're not
adapting
to civilian life
and
there's got to be something
i can do we can do
to try to normalize talking about mental
health
and
i hope that
through
i hope this is the start of something
and
yeah period i hope that i can help guys
like me
adapt to civilian life
and talk about the [ __ ] that's haunting
them
there it is
how has it been for you since you got
back
not easy
uh
i have not been able to adapt to
civilian life
i have
significant
ptsd symptoms
uh
and
they're starting to scare me
uh
one thing the marine corps doesn't do
is
train you
about these things i believe
because
when i got back i
didn't understand what was going on with
my body
uh
i didn't understand anxiety um
i thought that was weakness
i thought
as i said before
i can bury this down
with drinking and
pills
and
i can remain combat ready
and that was not the case
i now
sleep maybe two hours a night
i
can't go anywhere without some kind of
weapon
i constantly feel
like i'm going to be attacked
it's
embarrassing i used i feel
like i used to be
a pillar of strength and
not just physical mental strength
there's
physical strength is one thing uh
mental strength is a whole another ball
game and
i believe i need help and i'm trying to
get that through the va
but
not to their fault or
they are falling short and it's not
because it's not because of lack of
trying
i don't believe they understand it
completely
i don't
believe they have the right people and
places to
talk about these things
uh to give you an example
and this therapist wasn't part of the va
but
i was going through some [ __ ] when i got
out and uh i was pretty much
my dad pretty much said go talk to a
therapist
so i did
i put it all out there to them and i'm
100 certain i scared the [ __ ] out of
them
but i told them a brief story about um i
think a combat experience and one of my
friends dying
and they compared it to their
grandmother passing away
uh
yes that's sad
and i can appreciate a family member
passing away but it doesn't come close
to
the things that we're talking about
and
you need to understand that as a
therapist the people
and this is just what i believe
the people that
need to be in the positions
of talking to guys like me
need to have gone through it
they need to understand this thing
this ptsd thing this the tbi
the uh
they need to understand this from a
first point a first person point of view
a first person's perspective they need
to have done it that's the only way you
can understand things like this
period
guys like me can smell
when you haven't when you're talking
about it and you haven't done it we
briefly talked about
uh stolen valor and guys talking about
things they didn't do
if you've done this [ __ ]
there's certain keywords and and certain
jargon and
phrases you pick up on
and you can just tell
when someone's just taking a story that
they heard online or from a video game
or
someone close to them went through it so
they told it
we know
you're not slick
you know what i mean and
to me that's disgusting
that's why to me i've gone
unfortunately i've had to do these
programs these va programs these
therapy programs
and when you do enough of them
it becomes clear they don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about
not that i do
but what they're doing isn't helping
and
it's because they don't fully understand
it
to
i don't even know where to start with
this but
to
to help these people
you need to understand this fully
that's the only that's the first thing
we need to institute
put guys like me or maybe not even like
me
guys that have somewhat been through
these instances
been through combat in positions
to help
other people that are suffering
that needs to happen
otherwise we won't take it seriously
um and a lot of these programs that i've
been in
guys are just going in there
that that are actually
have
psychiatric problems they're not
combat related they're not
they
they need to institute something that
separates people that just have
issues from other things
and then
guys that
have been in combat
and it's affecting their lives
because
it's making the caregivers not
understand the difference between the
two
and
i i know i've said it but we can
and
when you're going through
a program and there's guys in there that
are milking the system or
in there
and they haven't actually been in combat
do you think i want to tell my story now
or
or talk about the things i went through
when
there's guys that you're telling the
same [ __ ] you're telling me i don't know
if i'm making sense right now but i'm
i'm trying to articulate what i'm
talking about and it's difficult keep in
mind i have
serious tbi
and sometimes i can't put what's in my
brain out of my mouth
you've been back how long
got out in 14 so
six seven years
how has this impacted the relationships
in your life significantly
towards the negative side
it's
wearing my family thin
no one in my family has ever been in
combat or been in the military or
they don't really understand it
and
i can't blame them for that
um
but they see me suffering and they don't
know how to help
are you a different person now
completely
i used to be outgoing
i have a positive outlook on life
i'm an introvert now
i don't leave my house my apartment
i hate people
and
maybe that's me just
being overly negative
but
i can't hold down a job
and it's not because i'm not a hard
worker
or i'm not
skilled in some profession
like
one of the things is i can't sleep
it's very hard for me to
get to work at 4 30 5 30 when i've slept
an hour two hours
uh
or i
have trouble with authority now um
i i could have a list for you why i
can't um
my body's starting to fail me as well
and i've always
i've always been a big gym guy and when
your body starts to fail you
it's
scary when you depend on your your
physical attributes
and they start breaking down
it's scary
every job that i've ever had
has been physical in some degree
i need to somehow
start using this
and
i haven't
been able yet hopefully this is the
start of something
that i can build and
grow and
turn into something successful
by helping guys like me and i i did it i
had a
i had a a
a very good friend of mine
go through the same exact thing that i
went through
and
i helped him i i talked with him through
things
i
got him in the military i
i helped him and that showed me that i
can do this i can understand veteran's
struggles and i can help people like me
and i know that's vague
but
and i don't really know
where to start with this but
i know
as i said before the stolen valor thing
if if guys are
faking this and trying to be like people
like me i know i have something
i know things that i've done are unique
and i need to somehow
build on that
and use it to my advantage um but
the first thing we need to do is
address these mental
these
mental health issues
and we're not
we're not
being completely open about them really
that's just from my point of view what i
think
um
but hopefully that will change
what's your view on war in general now
i'm
i'm disgusted about the way we got out
of afghanistan
um
it's almost like
everything we did
was for nothing
and i know i'm not the only one that
feels that way
but
the taliban's back in control
so
what exactly did we accomplish over
there
i couldn't tell you
but
war is necessary
you just need
good leaders
and
unfortunately we have fell
short on that
um
that's all i'll really say on that
but
do you regret enlisting
no
no
no i don't really regret much
i did what i did for the marine to the
right and left of me
we didn't do it for some politician or
when the [ __ ] hits the fan
you you want to bring your brothers home
you're just thinking about home
you're getting back
um
i'm
i'm kind of glad that i did that i i i
feel like i'm a part of history now
um
i just hope that it wasn't for for
nothing
and i hope that we can help the guys
that actually
did things over there
that's it
that's all it comes down to
but
what's the most important lesson you've
learned after all of this
how old do you know
32 32
what's the most important thing you've
learned
that's a
that's a tough one
i'd say
realize you only have one life
take care of yourself
uh
take care of your loved ones
tell them don't hold grudges
tell them you love them now
i've seen death
and
you know the scariest thing is there's
not
it looks like nothing
i went over there
religious and now
i'm not
it's not anyone's fault but
when you're around that element enough
you start realizing
what it really is
and
you find yourself not being able to
believe there's a god and all that of
course after seeing all that of course
how could there be
not i'm by no means am i knocking anyone
that does
i've seen that help a lot of people
i just personally
i [ __ ] hope there is
uh
but
unfortunately uh
right now in my life i don't believe
that unfortunately
do you feel like being a marine
made you a better man
oh 100
100
it's made me
better at reading people
i feel like i've been in front of
hundreds of different people
um after i
took a round to the dome i uh
i actually um
you got hit my head yeah i uh
i was trained in something
called bat and hides
and basically that was the system we
were using at the time
to log the taliban it's like a
so you scan someone's retina you type
their name in where they're from
uh
any
identifying body marks let me say
they're missing a finger tattoo you log
it into that
and you have to talk to them through an
interpreter and i can't tell you how
many
taliban guys i've
talked to through an interpreter but
when they saw i could understand their
language
and talk their language it broke them
down completely they started it's almost
like they respected me somewhat that i
took the time to learn hey and how are
you and where are you from in their
language
and it went a long way for me i i
learned some things
that i wasn't expecting to hear from
these guys and
some things they told me actually
rattled me like these dudes actually
like you gotta understand the type of
person these guys are these are
the way these guys live is astounding
because they are in a desert
they
have zero money
and they are choosing
to bang it out with the american
military
that's a certain type of individual
they literally believe
they're going to heaven with 72 virgins
i mean
or
something to that accord
because the things that they do that
they are willing the lengths that
they're willing to go
they got to believe something like that
because
it takes a certain type of individual to
strap
ordnance to their body c4 or some form
of explosive and [ __ ]
get on a bike and drive into a [ __ ]
up armored vehicle
you gotta be a certain caliber a person
i tell you like
you saw that happen oh yeah
multiple times
suicide run yeah
so
at a uh
when you're a low rank and i think at
the time i was a lance corporal which is
the third rank
in the marines
when someone suicide bomb happens or
something like that you gotta bag and
tag the evidence
so you gotta go pick up the pieces
so
i would pick up faces legs
and we would have to id them we'd have
to bring them back to a base camp
and try to i
d the dna or
get an eyeball and try to do a retina
scan
it'll put hair in your chest real quick
how does that affect you emotionally
that's that goes into the whole
believing in god thing like
i don't know i i just you gotta turn off
emotionally everything absolutely 100
there's no room for emotions
that's one thing over there there's
i don't think there's any there's no god
in afghanistan
picking up pieces of
human beings whether they're afghan
american or what just i don't think
that's something that should happen
but it
does i've done it
so what's it like for the afghans you've
been there what's it like for the
natives
not good
uh
what's it like to be an afghan
i unfortunately
got a first-hand view of a
afghan child growing up around a group
of men and they're referred to as chai
boys because
that's all i do is bring tea to them all
day but
what isn't shown so unfortunately or at
least the area that i was in
all afghan males are gay
they
listen i i don't know about other areas
but in helmand province
they
strictly look at women
for procreation
and they [ __ ] each other
the men do the men do yes and uh they
literally walk around holding hands
and
unfortunately as a young
i think there was probably
30 afghans with me and there was maybe
two or three kids
and they would literally pass them
around and gang rape them
that's what you have to look forward to
as an afghan
boy
bringing tea and oh
i think it was christmas
they had a
little party for us
and
they played their music brought us food
and they really showed us what their
culture was about they're dancing with
each other
belly dancing
uh and
there's just a bunch of straight
machine gunner killer marines in the
corner looking around like uh
where the [ __ ] did i park my car like
what the [ __ ] is this this is men and
women afghan
only men women don't come out women stay
in the house the men are belly dancing
oh yeah
uh
it was
very shocking to be around and i
unfortunately
walked in on a child being
[ __ ]
and i had to be held back
and explained this is
their culture bro
uh unfortunately we gotta let them rock
and that was just
so absurd to me
like
a child is to me
the
lowest
the most innocent thing that we have as
human beings as a child
and to do that
is just absolutely the lowest
form of filth
that slithers around this [ __ ]
earth
and
i believe they all deserve a bullet in
the [ __ ] head
period
um
and that was really
that turned me off of them for sure
because
being around that all the time it gets
like it's just too much and i i had no
idea that that was their culture and i'm
not saying this because i i'm hating on
them or i don't like them
i saw it
um
yeah well
so so imagine there's a draft in 2022
and all this new generation of men that
are
are males
who are painting their using nail polish
in their
nails wearing women's clothes and
they're
they're worried about their social media
and stuff like this have to go
they put a rifle in their hands and they
have to go off to russia or you know
anything's possible now china before i
go off on this um
i have gay friends
i'm not a hater
not homophobic
that's their choice
go for it
i don't see
the
men
of today
i don't see them on a rifle range that's
a damn sure
then again
a lot of these kids are
i feel like they're really just trying
to create chaos through what they're
doing with their looks
i feel like a lot of them
that's all they want to do is just post
a weird picture on instagram and get a
bunch of people going back and forth
it's a troll
it's uh
which is
[ __ ] like
why
but
putting them in a combat situation
there's no instagram there i mean you're
a special breed but i can't imagine a
lot of this new generation going through
anything close to what you went through
it wouldn't happen they'd be killed
they'd be slaughtered and
it would be a mockery of our armed
forces
but drafts are part of life sometimes
that's true
but there's
jobs for everyone
um
you know what i mean um
[Music]
for example we had uh
a few special individuals that were
with us to
i love the kid
i'm not gonna name drop
keep in mind he was a grunt he was an
infantry guy
uh we were going through
going through a gear inspection and uh
do you know what mvgs are night vision
goggles
so he had a m4 with a 203 on 203
launcher on it uh 203 shoots a grenade
he thought uh the 203 was his nvg holder
so he put his night vision goggles in
his 203 that's supposed to hold a
grenade
and when he was getting his gear
inspected it fell out and everyone's
like
what's going on he's like that's the uh
mpg holder right like no bro
but that's
similar to what would happen to these
these people like i mean
there's always special ones and those
are
not allowed to leave the wire they're
not allowed to go into combat
because they ultimately they won't pull
the trigger
and the marines especially if if you're
in the marines and
you're go through a combat situation and
you freeze up or
you can't
do what needs to be done
it does you don't last long
you get
put in a position where
you are
cleaning butts out of the sandpit or
you're
raking leaves somewhere
or you're
there's special jobs for everyone and
[Music]
the people that you're talking about
will be part of the special crew um
there'd be a lot of them now yeah oh
yeah i mean you always need guys to turn
big rocks into little rocks um
or
these guys are not going to be
in front line positions i'm telling you
there's certain jobs for them we got
we're gonna have a lot of cooks you know
they're gonna be put in
[Music]
situations where
they're they're gonna either be running
the mess halls or
they're gonna be gonna be a lot of cooks
a lot of cooks yeah
but there are other there were other
guys
you were fighting with that were cut
from your cloth
oh yeah
uh
i brought up
someone earlier with my driver so
cervantes
he was a corporal at the time he's now i
believe he's a gunnery sergeant still in
i saw this man
take an ied hit
and i'm pretty sure his ankle was next
to blown off
uh
get out of the truck and start yelling
at everyone to get into a position
set up a cordon he's on the radio
calling in
uh kazzavac for our captain keep in mind
he's [ __ ] up he's bleeding he's
bleeding out he's got
shrapnel coming out of his body sorry
that's my stress ball
anyways
cervantes
absolute stud
there's certain guys in combat
that you try to emulate
and
[Music]
that was one of them for me
always
doing the things that no one wants to do
setting the example just the leader and
abs you see
guys like that throughout your
time in the military that are absolute
studs that you try to emulate yourself
after
um
cervantes cervantes was one of them for
me
always af as i said we ran patrols in
the morning patrols at night we sat
security
after all that's done he's outside
working on the trucks
he's cleaning the weapons
and
setting the example for all of us what
we should be doing
um
trying to think of someone else that i
may be forgetting
but there there are guys there's there's
guys throughout the marine corps that
our leaders that set the example that
you
[Music]
to be the marine
that you need to be you need to emulate
you need to pick things from what
they're doing and you need to
you need to do them yourself what are
the personality traits that uh
that a young man needs in order to
do it you did i mean it's it's it's
part part of it is being a leader but
you also need to be humble you need to
be humble right humble
uh
that's what the marines break you down
and yeah don't go into a situation
thinking you know everything
when i was in you saw that
a lot with boot officers new officers so
there's enlisted and then there's
officers and officers don't go through
boot camp like the enlisted guys do they
basically do college and they do a
they do a officer boot camp at quantico
but it doesn't it's nowhere near what we
do
and they end up getting attached to
units like mine and they kind of go into
situations some go into situations like
they know everything
and it doesn't go well for them and
others
they're smart they're humble
and they ask the salty corporal or the
guy that they see doing [ __ ] running the
show hey what do i do in this situation
you know what
what's uh
what's supposed to be done when this
happens if you humble yourself
and you
you select the right guy to ask
questions
the boys will take care of you and uh
that means a lot to a
to a salty corporal or a sergeant when
an officer says hey
i see you running the show brother you
know what do i do in this situation what
can i do here
be humble it goes a long way
all right nick
thank you so much for sharing your story
thanks mark
amazing
you